[Musique]
nous allons parler avec vous du rôle du
ministère russe des affaires étrangères
dans le rapatriement de nos citoyens de
l'étranger comment cela s'est-il passé
notre constitution stipule que nous
devons garantir les droits de nos
citoyens y compris à l'étranger est bien
comme ça dans les faits hawass au
ministère des affaires étrangères de son
chargé dans quelle mesure le ministère
des affaires étrangères de méthyle être
appliquée parce que en principe
l'obligation pour un ministère des
affaires étrangères et de garantir les
droits et la sécurité de ses citoyens à
l'étranger par tous les moyens
juridiques internationaux à disposition
est prévue par la législation de tous
les pays nous ne faisons pas exception
en revanche dans toute une série de cas
dans tel ou tel pays
quand on le peut pro gold les mécanismes
impliquant une contribution rapatriement
s'avère n'avoir pas été établie une fois
pour toutes at on compris qu'il fallait
rapatrier nos citoyens et qu'ils étaient
très nombreux la décision était prise
par le centre opérationnel nous en
faisons partie avec le ministère du
développement numérique et des
communications qui garantit la base
numérique de tout ce travail
le ministère des transports le service
fédéral de surveillance de la protection
des droits des consommateurs et du bien
être humain rospotrebnadzor
le ministère de l'intérieur pour les
problèmes migratoires et le fsb pour les
questions frontalières naturel chez atom
dans ce cas les principales décisions
concernant le durcissement puis
l'abaissement des mesures de restriction
de la circulation sont évidemment prise
en tenant compte des avis analyses du
rospotrebnadzor courts spots et du
ministère de la santé et du centre
opérationnel dirigé par la vice
présidente du gouvernement tatiana
golikova qui supervise les questions
relatives à la santé
comment avez vous compris que disons
deux cent cinquante mille personnes
avaient besoin d'être rapatrié en russie
ce qui était en voyage organisé ont été
rapatriés assez rapidement le principal
travail a porté sur les autres sortes de
touristes et pas seulement les touristes
des personnes se trouvaient à l'étranger
pour différentes raisons
la plus grande partie bien sûr était
constitué de touristes
on ne voit pas très bien ici quelle est
la différence entre voyages organisés et
tourisme individuel moment nous n'avons
pas de restrictions à la sortie du pays
je ne vois pas la différence avec un
voyage organisé le touriste a
obligatoirement un billet retour et les
engagements des opérateurs touristiques
c'est à dire pour ceux qui sont partis
en voyage organisé individuel peut
partir sans billet retour car il ne sait
pas encore combien de temps il voudra
rester à l'étranger il pas qui coiffe
une longueur ils sont nombreux je vous
assure que l'on ne t'avait premiers mots
no 10 et qu'un taux de plus hormis les
personnes qui sont simplement parti
passer du temps à l'étranger pour se
reposer aux bernois
il existe un autre groupe de citoyens
russes qui se trouvaient à l'étranger
pour étudier ou frais des deux à grenier
de hollywood
l'ubs à le suivre un traitement médical
et niveau pendant encore en résidence
permanente de tous ceux ils ont
soudainement constaté que les conditions
de vie notamment aux états unis par
exemple à new york s'était dégradée à
cause de l'infection
ils ont décidé qu'il serait plus sûr de
rentrer en russie et se sont inscrits
sur le site des services d'état pour
revenir pour nous travaillons pour
appliquer les décisions du centre
opérationnel nord prise avant tout en
fonction de la situation épidémiologique
du chef dans sa partie qui concerne
l'organisation directe du regroupement
de l'information de l'embarquement de
nos citoyens qui reviennent de
l'étranger
en fait c'est tout ce qu'il faut
regroupement informations embarquement
que footing d'autres nous nous je dois
dire look sobre virements et il faut
trouver un vol gêné peau dans un premier
temps il a été décidé qu'un maximum de
500 personnes par jour pouvait revenir à
moscou et dans la région de moscou est
un maximum de 200 personnes dans
d'autres régions
malgré le retour de la grande majorité
il reste encore au moins vingt mille de
nos citoyens que nous n'avons pas encore
réussi à rapatrier pourtant mouche toit
ni loi trop de sauts
parce qu'il se trouve à l'étranger dans
des endroits difficiles d'accès pour
l'aviation russe
quel endroit cela peut être en océanie
ou dans des îles aux philippines en
amérique latine aux thèses en amérique
latine également été musclé où les
endroits exotiques sont souvent éloignés
de la civilisation
autrement dit il faut encore les
rassembler pour les faire revenir il
faut créer un pôle de départs importants
grossistes puis en russie créé un autre
pôle d'arrivée soit à partir duquel les
régions de la fédération de russie
concernés accueilleront sous leur
responsabilité
ces individus et garantiront à tout ce
que les citoyens rapatriés seront placés
en quarantaine
c'est le plus compliqué actuellement au
niveau de notre ministère il est pris en
charge par le centre de coordination qui
travaillent sans exagération 24 heures
sur 24
l'autopsié le centre des situations de
crise tous les départements territoriaux
en fonction de la région du monde
concerné est évidemment le département
d'information et de la presse parce que
ses collaborateurs sont en première
ligne
pourquoi ce département d'un côté c'est
notre porte parole au poste de l'autre
la drees du ministère des affaires
étrangères à laquelle tout citoyen de
notre pays et même d'autres pays peut
envoyer ses propositions roquettes et
exigence d'outils arrive que des
félicitations comme des critiques et
comment est organisé le travail de tout
ce groupe de coordination au ministère
des affaires étrangères s'est il
organisait de lui même
sinon c'était ma directive elle a été
signée il ya longtemps à la mi mars
le vice-ministre supervise ce travail
tous les départements mentionné ils sont
représentés nous sommes également
représentée au niveau du vice-ministre
au centre opérationnel dirigé par la
vice présidente du gouvernement
tatiana golikova nous travaillons au
sein du groupe de coordination du
conseil d'état dirigé par le maire de
moscou sergueï sobianine
vous vous attendiez une telle affluence
ian young
honnêtement je n'ai pas été surpris
franchement ils auraient pu être plus
nombreux n'ont ni de la situation était
confuse avec ceux qui comme je les dis
se sont installés à l'étranger et ont
soudainement décidé qu'il était plus sûr
de rentrer vers l'os et là j'arrive pas
à comprendre les listes se sont
agrandies avec eux ce que nous
rapatrions disons cinq mille personnes
et les listes augmentait d'encore 10
milles voilà quelque chose que je ne
comprends pas du tout moi non plus les
individus se sont installés à l'étranger
oui réside aux états unis et le
ministère des affaires étrangères et la
fédération de russie avec l'argent de la
fédération de russie
les rapatriés en russie pourquoi nous
nous sommes à dieu n'y avait pas tout à
fait avec l'argent de la fédération de
russie les billets ont un prix l'état
russe verse à toutes les personnes
inscrites sur le site et qui
correspondent aux critères car il y en a
what's on touche des allocations de
24000 2401 2400 excusez-moi 2400 roubles
par jour par adulte et celle à venir
toucher 24 milles par jour
oui oui vous voyez ce sont mes rêves qui
parle mais ce sont des gens c'est leur
décision
c'est leur vie après tout
nous ne posons pas de questions on nous
mais ils ont ce droit
ce sont des citoyens russes y l'homme
autrement dit cela nous est égal
non bien sûr nous voulons faire en sorte
que les gens soient dans une situation
confortable
pas nous je répète qu indépendamment des
décisions qui ont été prises auparavant
s'il pense que pour garantir leurs
intérêts il faut rentrer de solitude
alors qui peut s'y opposer
j'estime qu'on ne peut pas faire cela
selon vous nous considérons comme un
autre tous les individus qui sont
citoyens de la fédération de russie il
n'y a qu'un moyen d'être citoyen russe
d'un passeport posséder un passeport et
nous considérons comme notre tous les
gens qui possèdent aussi par exemple un
passeport américain ou pas oui parfois
on dit avec exaltation
on n'abandonne pas les siens c'est
précisément le cas il ya eu certes ce
qu'on appelle des ratés de cela arrive
toujours dans le cadre d'un travail de
grande ampleur il y a parfois des
lacunes brio le no il ya beau je n'ai
pas vraiment été surpris je savais que
dans leur grande majorité
nos collaborateurs se sont montrés très
réactifs mais dans de nombreuses
ambassades
ils ont fait preuve je dirais d'une
créativité particulière au népal en
himalaya nous en avons déjà parlé
les collaborateurs de l'ambassade sous
la direction de l'ambassadeur il dispose
d'un grand territoire depuis l'époque
soviétique ont installé un campement
pour ceux qui étaient venus faire du
tourisme sauvage ou tout simplement ne
pouvait se permettre de loger à l'hôtel
ils ont tout simplement été logées dans
des tentes
ils vivaient dans des tentes notre
mission diplomatique acheter de la
nourriture avec l'argent des
collaborateurs autrement dit les
collaborateurs se cotisait oui pas
l'état maintenant évidemment tout est
fait de manière organisée mais il
fallait commencer sur le tas moi
personne ne s'imaginait l'ampleur que
prendrait le problème
washington ne s'était encore occupé du
rapatriement d'un tel nombre de citoyens
il y a eu d'autres situations comme
après le tsunami en thaïlande
tout le monde a été rapatrié dans ce
pays il y avait plusieurs stations
balnéaires
mais une seule destination aérienne et à
cette époque des vols charters avec nos
touristes à bord partait dans l'autre
sens certains fuyaient d'autres
partaient en vacances parce qu'ils
avaient des bn c'est un nombre de
personnes absolument incomparable
bien sûr la thaïlande n'est que l'une
des dizaines de destinations où il faut
rapatrier les citoyens aujourd'hui
plusieurs milliers de nos citoyens sont
encore en thaïlande
nombre d'entre eux ont décidé de ne pas
tenter le diable tout beau il ne pas
revenir
du moins pour la période de la pandémie
il préfère attendre là bas après tout
tout dépend si la personne en question
peut se permettre de rester à l'étranger
ou non les nouveaux jeux bien sûr il est
évident que nous vivons dans un pays où
la plupart des gens ne peuvent pas se le
permettre
bien sûr la plupart des gens achètent un
voyage où généralement tout est inclus
dont le temps et les services fournis
sont généralement limitées au second
poteau
en fait il s'agit de sommes assez
modeste pour la plupart des gens ce sont
de sérieuses dépenses d'eau et s'il
achète un tel voyage autour retard au
delà de la période de vacances payées
pose un sérieux problème
c'est pourquoi l'aide accordée par
l'état est une chose très importante
comment l'état et donc le ministère
russe des affaires étrangères
évalue-t-il la responsabilité des
citoyens des citoyens sont par qui ils
ont acheté des voyages
après tout ils devaient réfléchir c'est
une question de morale
mais vous en tant qu'homme et en tant
que ministre des affaires étrangères je
ne peux donner mon avis je dois
appliquer la constitution de la
fédération de russie
il n'est pas écrit dans la constitution
que vous devez rapatrier les citoyens
avec votre argent
c'est également une question de morale
en tant qu'individu je peux moralement
avoir mon propre avis sur le risque que
comportait un départ houleux durant la
seconde moitié du mois de mars vers les
pays chauds tout en sachant que
l'ampleur de la pandémie avait été
approximativement évalué par tous les
médias mais j'ai aussi une attitude
morale envers ceux qui ont simplement
aider des gens autonomes ceux qui se
sont retrouvés sans argent nous en
pensée à la constitution ou de mort
[Musique]
au plus mal
colas nous avons indiqué à plusieurs
reprises que plus de 60 étudiants russe
s'était retrouvé aux états unis sans que
les autorités russes n'avaient été
informés il ya ici une ong avec laquelle
travaille une institution américaine qui
organise des études pour les étrangers
et dans ce cadre il paye certains frais
le transport
ils sont logés dans des familles
américaines robin et dans des régions
éloignées de divers états ils suivent
des cours dans des universités et des
écoles
il ya eu plus de 60 cas comme ça gomis
maintenant seulement 6 je crois sont
toujours là bas
benoît costil beaucoup d'entre eux ont
été ramenés à new york par
l'intermédiaire de nos diplomates loisy
le new york dans de nombreux cas ils
leur ont même acheté des billets
personnellement d'avion ou de train
oui donc d employée de notre ambassade
les ont achetés à leurs propres frais
oui et ce sans aucun ordre ni directives
prix cazes pourquoi faire ça
notamment parce qu'il est important de
résoudre ce problème soutient au
problème comment peut-on faire autrement
des mineurs reste dans une famille
américaine ne signifie quand la pandémie
a commencé dans certains cas du des
familles américaines ont dit au garçon
ou la fille douce merci beaucoup
nous t'avons assure un logement quand
tout allait bien mais maintenant la
situation est différente et nous cessons
donc de collaborer avec ce programme
le pack yodimi je pense qu'ici la
question pourquoi ne se pose même pas si
c'est une envie sincère d'aidé c'est
admirable
elles méritent des encouragements sont
aujourd'hui pas chez nous
vous attendiez-vous à une telle
implication personnelle de nos services
consulaires des ambassades
gageons oui j'ai travaillé à l'étranger
je sais que tout le monde est différent
non ce n'est pas moi mais un diplomate
normalement constitué newzoo lobsinger
qui les connexions neuronales sont
encore sensibles à ce qui se passe dans
le monde
généralement aider les gens qui se sont
retrouvés dans une situation
extraordinaire moi je tape bien sûr une
personne ne pouvait prévoir l'ampleur de
la catastrophe eu ce taureau où il était
impossible de créer à l'échelle de
l'état des structures en prévision de
quelque chose de ce type
maintenant bien sûr des conclusions vont
être tirés de bandes audio et quelles
conclusions vont être tirés je ne sais
pas je ne sais pas rejouer avant tout
les conclusions devront porter sur notre
capacité doit tourner the dance à réagir
face à la répétition d'une telle
pandémie au bolchoï surtout étant donné
que de plus en plus de spécialistes
évoquent la possibilité d'une deuxième
vague dans ce sens nos épidémiologistes
devrait jouer le rôle le plus important
d'autres personnes notamment pour ce qui
concerne la mise en place d'institutions
médicales spécialisées en russie des
nosotros tokyo preuve de rossi et
callisto bourse les hôpitaux qui ont été
construits et qui n'ont pas un caractère
temporaire sont des hôpitaux avec un
très bon équipement avec des appareils
nécessaires et des moyens de protection
assez sérieusement et je suis sûr qu'ils
resteront en place de brut sur renault
animaux dont ils seront sans doute
réorienter entre les épidémies si il y à
une deuxième vague mais c'est le plus
important voire et bien sûr une décision
va probablement être prochainement
prises sur la question de la reprise des
communications avec le monde extérieur
aériennes ferroviaires et routières
ces décisions seront évidemment prises
en fonction de l'expérience que nous
vivons actuellement
et que fera le ministère des affaires
étrangères nous sommes au bout du monde
nous allons en tant que ministère des
affaires étrangères fournir des
informations quant à la situation
pandémique dans les pays étrangers
ces informations seront envoyés par le
ministère des affaires étrangères aux
institutions russes qui évalueront de
manière professionnelle
les risques de livres pour par exemple
l'europe s'ouvre actuellement et compte
tenu du nombre de cas d'infections
identifier la russie comme les états
unis et le brésil est pour l'heure
considéré comme un pays où les
déplacements ne sont pas encore
autorisés
non mais le brésil sa aca incroyable
c'est monstrueux si on parle des
personnes infectées chez nous chez nous
c'est 8000 par jour ce n'est pas autant
déjà moins de 8000 voilà c'est ce que je
dis et ce nombre diminue mais le nombre
total s'élève tout de même à des
centaines de milliers et c'est beaucoup
tendance mieux par contre le taux de
mortalité chez nous est plus bas les
spécialistes devraient particulièrement
discuté de ce sujet est que lorsqu il
est important que les statistiques soit
unifiée on me souffle actuellement les
statistiques sont différents chez tout
le monde chez google dans certains pays
et sont tout à fait libérale c'est à
dire qu'on ajoute tout le monde dans
cette catégorie
quand il y a des cas mortels dans
d'autres pays elles sont réparties en
différentes causes non je ne suis pas
expert en la matière mais nous
fournirons à notre gouvernement en temps
réel des informations concernant la
situation épidémiologique à l'étranger
et de la façon dont les pays s'ouvre aux
vieux vous conteste que l'on pourra
rouvrir les frontières
je ne sais pas nous commençons petit à
petit à revenir à la vie normale n'est
pas le
en sortant de cette période de
visioconférence nous en avons tenu plus
d'une quinzaine si je ne me trompe pas
ovi compris de très importantes comme la
visioconférence des ministres des
affaires étrangères de l'organisation du
traité de sécurité collective de la
communauté des états indépendants de
l'organisation de coopération de
shanghai de l'asian russie j'ai déjà
reçu en personne de collègues
le ministre iranien des affaires
étrangères la semaine dernière et le
ministre vénézuélien des affaires
étrangères cette semaine et de mon côté
et pour la première fois depuis trois
mois je suis allé à l'étranger en serbie
et en biélorussie
les deux visites avaient été prévues
pour le mois de mars on ne dirait pas
vraiment que la biélorussie étape et
étrangers pourquoi c'est notre voisin
vous savez qu'actuellement tout le monde
va à l'étranger via la biélorussie est
turc est ouvert ses frontières bellavia
et turkish airlines ont déjà repris des
vols un minimum
nous ne pouvons pas interdire aux gens
d'utiliser cette opportunité par contre
il faut faire preuve de prudence et de
réserve et ce morceau quand on prend de
telles décisions
beaucoup de grands pays ont rapatrié
leurs citoyens de ces points chauds en
quoi notre méthode est elle différente
de celle par exemple de l'allemagne ou
des états unis
quelle est la différence de manière
générale ne soit qu'une personne a été
gratuitement rapatrier nulle part si li
tout le monde prend après donc signé une
reconnaissance de dette qui à son tour
la somme en question sera remboursé
c'est aussi un prêt oui c'est aussi un
prêt dans notre cas tout a été fait en
fonction de la possibilité de placer les
gens en quarantaine vous avez commencé à
dire que pendant trois mois trois mois
et demi tout le monde vivait systéme
zoom sur l'application zoom
objet vie c'est mieux le monde entier a
commencé à communiquer à distance
le président antony et ya encore des
réunions à distance dans quelle mesure
tout cela a modifié le travail de l'état
et notamment du ministère des affaires
étrangères nos besoins et c'est beau
vous savez on peut aussi une telle
pandémie avait eu lieu il ya dix ans
nous serions sans doute retrouver dans
une situation beaucoup plus compliquée
pour ce qui est du fonctionnement normal
du ministère des affaires étrangères
[Musique]
cela a été possible à notre époque
après une incorporation assez large des
méthodes de communication modernes dans
le travail du ministère des affaires
étrangères et d'autres structures
fédérales et régionales le maire bientôt
d'autres comme en écosse cela n'a pas
été très difficile pour nous de mettre
en place ce travail en ligne euros noir
nous n'avons éprouvé aucune difficulté
particulière d'entrer ressentiez vous
quelque chose d'inhabituel pendant les
réunions avec le président nous en
général vous venez au kremlin pour
savoir ce qui était bizarre ce n'était
que ça ne se passe pas en personne mais
via un écran mais non vous savez tout
cela fonctionne de manière assez
efficace et oui la communication
personnelle surtout quand il s'agit de
négociations avec un partenaire étranger
pas de négociation pour la forme parce
qu'il y à des visites
appelons-les visite de politesse quand
lundi que tout va bien chez nous après
l'autre dit que tout est excellent et
convient d'autres rencontres j'exagère
un peu mais il ya des visites facile on
n'a pas l'objectif de négocier on est de
résoudre un problème à tout prix à ce
moment précis la de baraki quand de tels
problèmes sont à l'ordre du jour de
négociations concrètes
c'est déjà plus difficile de les
résoudre en ligne là il faut voir les
yeux et pas seulement les yeux sur un
écran mais en personne il ya des choses
qu'on peut difficilement confié même
pendant la visioconférence la mieux
protégée
les officiers c'est un côté humain il
faut le comprendre
non mais je pense qu'une fois que se
sera calmée au cas que j'espère bientôt
nous continuerons à utiliser certains
éléments de ce travail
surtout quand il s'agit des partenaires
à qui il est difficile de rendre visite
d'un point de vue logistique ni par
exemple en amérique du sud
c'est toute une histoire et l'on prend
son écran allumé c'est tout un ivrogne
heureux quand ils planifient leurs
missions à l'étranger ils doivent relier
trois quatre cinq pays extra pour ne pas
perdre 15 16 heures chaque fois pour un
aller simple vous n'avez pas être
affectée par le corps d'un virus
mon dieu merci pas encore on ne sait pas
vous aurez pu avoir une forme légère et
pourriez déjà être immunisé il est caché
les employés du ministère des affaires
étrangères ont ils étaient nombreux ce
qui est bien nous avons des cas des
quelques dizaines dans l'appareil
central et dans les départements
nous avons des départements territoriaux
dans les régions clés de la fédération
de russie où il y a beaucoup de consul
étrangers autour de 40 au cours des
auditions la majorité écrasante à une
forme légère
un seul cas mortels c'est un personnage
et j'ai 62 ans il sait pas gêne au
niveau audio domoni balshaw sa femme
fait partie du personnel médical
ce n'est pas un secret travailler dans
une ambulance et elle a dû être porteuse
asymptomatiques de symptômes mais nous
respectons strictement toutes les
recommandations du rospotrebnadzor du
département de la santé de moscou
y compris quand il s'agit de travail à
distance
oda l'homme de robe presque la moitié de
nos employés se sont mis à travailler à
distance dès le début et continue de le
faire
et vous comment nous pouvons travailler
en distance non vous personnellement je
suis obligé de venir voir et comme tout
le monde je travaille dans mon bureau
ah bon donc vous n'avez jamais travaillé
à distance des nues non mais je suis
suivi moi aussi je communique avec un
grand nombre de personnes nous sommes
régulièrement testé plusieurs fois par
semaine nous avons tous les moyens de
protection individuelle pour les
visiteurs les visiteurs sont moins
nombreux nous essayons principalement de
résoudre les problèmes via des
conversations téléphoniques
merci de penser à nous
merci à vous
[Musique]